А можна об'єднати одразу щоб і
антимонопольний разом і Фонд держмайна і
рахункову палату бо це ж буде зручно це
буде класно скажіть як можна до такого
докотитись нагадаю всі посли Великої
сімки звернулись до парламенту сказали
не призначайте нових членів рахункової
палати не призначайте голову рахункової
палати до реформи цього органу І що
робите ви наплювали витерли ноги
призначаємо нам плювати А завтра скажуть
як же так де підтримка де міжнародна
підтримка чого нас не підтримують а чого
нам гроші не дають да тому що ми живемо
за їхній рахунок і вони говорять Ми
хочемо бачити як рахункова палата
контролює що ви не вкрадете це все а
Відповідь Яка українського парламенту
яка відповідь більшості родичку подроги
зеленських на посаду повний контроль